should i use the microphone okay
microphone is not working
try the second one
hello
hello
second one is also not
okay so i will have to speak up i guess
so
what
oh sorry
okay
so my name is radekeshek i work here at
atacama as a python engineer
and
i'm really excited and happy to see so
many people came here
i hope you didn't just come for the food
but i tried like really hard to put as
many buzzwords as possible in the
abstract so i guess it worked
so i hope it will be interesting for
everybody
so
it was introduced already so i will just
start
with the motivation and what the problem
really is
so
basically it's quite simple
like
you have power lines everywhere hundreds
of kilometers of them like ever since i
started this project i just noticed them
everywhere and like sometimes they go
through densely vegetated areas like
forests
and obviously like
there's the potential for a tree
colliding with the wires
and that's what you want to avoid so
there's one example of like what can
happen if the tree touches the wire it's
actually the
it's called the california campfire and
it's the biggest fire in the history of
california and it was caused by
a poorly maintained corridor in the
forest and actually the company the
pacific gas and electric uh was held
responsible for this and they faced like
30 billion dollars in liabilities and
they managed to like cut it down to 13.5
billion dollars that went to the victims
because actually 85 people died in this
fire so it's quite serious
uh
and then on the right
there's like the solution to the to the
problem so
it actually has two parts so first like
you you would imagine that you can just
cut down all the trees uh
like regularly but it's not possible you
have like hundreds of kilometers and
it's extremely expensive to do it like
every year everywhere so first you need
to identify the areas that are
problematic
uh so
and that then you can follow up and like
do this crazy thing which is a
helicopter that has actually a chainsaw
uh it's like a giant chainsaw cutting
the tree so i think it's kind of cool
but as you can imagine like it's
extremely expensive to do it regularly
so you need first to scout the locations
so that's that's our task like uh
actually the goal is to measure like the
distance between the the tree and the
wire and there is some legislation
around that uh so in czech republic uh
it depends on the voltage and like for
example for 220 kilovolts it needs to be
50
meters from the wire
so
that's what everybody's trying to
measure
and they were previously using different
methods to
achieve this for example satellites
uh or like sending people there but they
all have kind of disadvantages for
example the satellites are very low
resolution and extremely expensive and
people cannot go everywhere like
mountains
for example so they also try to use
helicopters and they are regularly using
helicopters but they are quite expensive
to
to run and they are not automated so
it's kind of a perfect application for a
drone which can be automated uh it's
light uh it can be easy operated by one
person without any like a special flight
permit so
it's actually quite good
so about the drone
uh so this is this is the drone that we
applied for this is the dji mattress 600
it's a professional drone it has like no
kind of safety mechanisms so if your
battery dies it just flies down
falls down
or like no obstacle avoidance whatsoever
so you are expected to know what you are
doing
and next to it we have the
uh it's a base station for like making
the gps signal more precise because the
drone
sometimes the
like the default gps sensors on the
drones are not that precise so sometimes
it like wiggles in the air and drops
altitude
so this helps improving the precision
and also we write the gps coordinates to
the images that the drop takes
so it also helps with the precision of
the image position
so this is the payload that we have uh
had on the drone
uh so it's a mirrorless camera with 25
millimeter lens it's mounted on this
gimbal which allows it to rotate all
around
and
then we have a few boxes we have the air
commander entire
which is a small computer that runs
linux and it writes
the gps positions into the metadata of
the images and it also triggers the
camera so
in case you are wondering like how
insanely complicated all this is like
there is uh like about five or six
computers on board of this and they all
have to work in sync
and
like for example the camera is triggered
by this led infrared light which because
this is apparently the way how we
control camera these days and it comes
the signal comes from this entire which
is connected through the wires with the
flight controller that is on top of the
drone
and then like you control it through
your remote control which is connected
to a phone which is connected to a
computer so it's like a quite
complicated thing to maintain
how do you make it fly so
as you can imagine
it's not easy like manually
to fly the drone for hundreds of
kilometers and be absolutely accurate
about the position of each image and
like because like all this what is all
of this boils down is that we want to
create a 3d model of the
terrain and of the wires and
there is a set of like standards and
procedures for building 3d models out of
images
and
you need uh
for example you need to maintain a
certain altitude a certain precision
like if your wires are two centimeters
thick then uh you need to see them at
least in two pixels
to be able to recognize that it's a wire
like if the
resolution is too small
then you wouldn't even see it on the
picture so
this kind of effects how fly how high
you can fly and also like you need to
sample the photographs regularly because
you want
some kind of
high overlap
you need like to see the same
spot on the ground from many different
angles and perspectives so
there is a software for it that
automates all of this
and you just like put in the properties
of your camera and
how much you want to overlap and how
precise and it will just generate the
flight path for you
so
basically you take off with the drone
you
climb up to several meters and then
click a button and the drone starts
flying on its own
now the drone that i showed you is cost
about half a million check rounds
and it's not insurable like no one will
uh insure it
like we tried but it's not possible to
do it so like
it's flying there on its own and you are
trying to some somehow it will work out
and it will not fall down because it has
no safety mechanisms so
it's a bit stressful but like on top of
that like the software gives you some
kind of like nice error messages all the
time some of them are useful some of
them are not
but always sounds like a nuclear
attack is about to come so
[Music]
so this is like the sort of sound that
you get uh every two minutes when the
drone is flying on its own uh
they are kind of worried think what is
happening so this happens when the
battery voltage is low uh there's the
next one that like you should probably
land at this point
but we didn't still like
very confident in the abilities
and then like this is my personal
favorite the execution could not be
executed like i have no idea what it
means
okay
okay so enough with the introduction now
let's get technical so
you
with this process you captured uh
some images so you have like a
group of images and they all have gps
coordination written into the metadata
and how do you build a 3d model out of
this or how do you actually measure
distances between the wires
and the trees
so i already spoiled it so you will
build a 3d model uh actually two 3d
models
one is of the terrain itself
this can be done like video standard
software that is available available on
the market but it's not very good with
thin homogeneous structures so it cannot
capture the
the wires because they look the same
across all of the photographs
and
then so so for that reason there will be
a second step which is the cornerstone
of the work uh which is the power line
reconstruction pipeline which will build
the 3d models of just the power lines
and then we will just combine them
together calculate the distances between
the two 3d models and that's the final
result
so
let's start with the photogrammetric
pipeline
so this is a
standard way
of building 3d models out of images uh
so there's plenty of software available
i chose one of the open source ones is
it's called open drone map
uh
it has like high quality algorithms but
it's a pain to work with like it ate up
about 300 or 200 gigabytes of memory so
it had to be run on like a powerful
cluster just to not crash
and it runs about 10 hours
for the resolution that we that we
needed
and
what it produces so like
actually how it works so
first there is a structure from motion
step
which is basically if you ever took a
panorama photo with your uh
phone and you wondered how that works uh
it basically like
finds some distinct points across the
images like some corners of objects or
like sharp uh
changes in the brightness of the
pixels and then it tries to match those
points across multiple images and from
that information like if you have the
same point in two different images and
you know where the images were taken you
can calculate the 3d location of the
point and you can build something that
is called a point cloud so which is
which is this image so the point cloud
is really just a set of points nothing
else it's a
they have xyz uh coordinate and they
have a color that's it
and then also like conveniently it
produces like information about the
cameras so you put in images and it
tells you like hey this this image was
taken here like the red dots represent
the
position of the camera but you also know
the rotation
and
you also know something that is called
camera intrinsic
which give you
uh
sort of the parameters of the lines like
the distortion that is happening so you
can correct for it so here you have a
fisheye lens
and you need to correct for it so it
actually appears straight and you need
to do this because every camera has this
kind of aberrations
so but if you want to take measurements
from the images and want to be at least
a little bit precise then you need to do
this step
so it's called image and distortion and
it actually produces the undistorted
images already
so
that's the turning point you can see
like some of the you can see the terrain
you can see the transmission towers and
like some of the wires were
reconstructed but like most of it is
missing and there are actually five
wires but only three are visible in this
uh cloud so
it's not use good for even though the
resolution was really high and we tried
a lot to have the best quality
reconstruction it's not possible to do
it just uh with this software so that's
where the second part comes in which is
the cornerstone of the work
and
so the goal of this part
is to build a 3d model of the wires
also the result will be a point cloud
but we will have like a deep geometric
understanding of each wire and how many
wires there are
and then we can like just combine the
point clouds and calculate how far they
are from each other and that's the
result
uh so all of these properties that came
from the uh
photogrammetric pipeline uh go in
at different points
but how can you achieve this so like
previously the model was done by some
standardized method now like
how do we
build the 3d models from set of images
of the wires
so the first thing you might
imagine is identifying the wires in the
images
so
identifying which pixels exactly from
the image
belong to the wire and which are
background so that's the power line
segmentation
so that's the first step
so you put in an image and you end up
with something like this which is the
binary segmentation mask it has zeros uh
it's an image it's a matrix it has zeros
for background ones for uh the wires
uh so there are like two very common
approaches how to do this one of them is
uh using the
traditional methods from computer vision
uh which basically
is in very like defined structured way
allows you to uh understand what's going
on and apply certain set of filters and
thresholds so in in this like this is
the original photograph in this first
step there is like a decoration stretch
just to like pre-processing step to even
out the histogram
of the
color values
then you apply some sort of edge
detector filter which if you know is
like a convolution with
a filter matrix it's very basic computer
vision operation is the same thing that
happens in convolutional neural networks
but now we have like a fixed filter that
we define
and the last step is just taking the
highest values from this image so this
produces some like
edges which are the
big transitions between like dark and
bright values so like the
uh the wires are right white on this
picture and the background is mostly
dark so there is it's identifying these
big uh
differences and if you take just the
highest the one percent of the highest
values you end up with with this image
and but
as you can see it's not perfect like
there's some noise uh and also like is
working
solely on the
edge detection so if there is some other
edge like a rail or a road underneath
the wires it will also detect it i will
show that later
so
that was the first approach and the
second most popular approach nowadays is
using the
neural networks
so
i also tried to use a neural network i
used it as a black box basically it was
pre-trained so uh i included this slide
for the architecture if you are neural
network fans but i don't really
understand it
but like the the input is here for
example the image of a cat and the
output is uh
it's very poorly visible there but it's
a segmentation mask so per pixel
classification of what object is there
maybe it will be more visible here so
the model the d-plot
v3 plus that i used was pre-trained on
the cityscapes data set
which example of it is here so it has
pixel-wise annotations for different
objects and it also has like these nice
thin gray poles that look kind of like
the wires
but actually i found another
data set that was open source available
on the internet
with nice
perfect annotations of the wires i just
removed the transmission towers because
they are not important for this and just
fine tune the model on this
and surprisingly it worked very well
so this is the comparison between the
traditional methods as you can see
there's like part of the transmission
tower there's some road
but the neural network kind of like
deeply understands the scenes and know
what is a wire and what is not a wire
hopefully
and
so it produces like cleaner uh
segmentation mask
so
the next step
that you need to do so this is not
enough it's like you have only
identified which pixels uh corresponds
to the wires but now you actually want
to know like yes i have five wires in
this image and they have like this uh
equation of the uh
of the line so they're like start at
this point and at this point
uh so
you can apply something that is called
half-line transformation
it's uh also from computer vision
and what it does is like
it's very complicated i will not explain
it but uh what it does it finds uh
lines in the images so it looks at the
pixels it needs the segmentation mask it
looks at the
things and it tries to identify lines
but it's not perfect and like for one
single line here it produces like tens
of lines so it's like a cluster or group
of lines
and also there is some noise for example
here so you need to filter all that out
and i just identify only the like that
this is one wire and not like 20.
so how you can do that it's
using uh clustering
basically so i like clustered uh the
the groups of lines that the algorithm
detected first based on angle so i
calculated the angle between the x-axis
and the
the line
and then i clustered like everything
that was further than one degree
uh was a separate cluster so you can see
it's actually visualized on this image
so this is one cluster green and red
is the corresponding three clusters
so that's not enough because we want
five not three
so you can then cluster it also based on
the distance to this point which is like
the beginning of the image and you get
nice five lines
so
now you have clusters and each cluster
corresponds to one power line but it
contains like
tens
of
detected lines
so how you can deal with that is just
like sample some points these are the
blue points from the lines and just fit
the line through them and you have a
nice geometric representation of the
thing
and actually like you also need to deal
with the curvatures of the wires because
the wires are not straight they can like
curve in the images so i just like split
the whole image into small vertical
segments i did this clustering in each
of them and then merge them back
together and had a nice like polyline
representation or segments of line
representation for each power line
so it has some drawbacks it's not
perfect like here you can see uh there's
like actually two wires
very close to each other it was detected
just as one uh but as long as you have
like at least seven pixels between
uh the two wires you can uh detect them
separately in most cases so
the words works pretty well
uh
so okay
so
now you have the images you know the
exact rotation position
uh
and how many power lines are there in
the images so you have a lot of
information and you need to combine it
from all the images into the 3d model
like
obtain the 3d points from the images
so how can you do this
so first
i would like sort of categorize the
images and like sort them and where each
image belongs so there is like uh
there's this view of the the red points
these are the
camera positions where the image was
taken you can just like look at it from
the bird bird eye view
and see them in 2d plane and then you
can actually classify like okay like
this is you can fit the line this the
blue line
and then based on the distance to the
line you can classify okay this is the
left strip this is the middle strip and
this is the right strip
and
the reason why there are colored is that
you actually want like groups of three
images one after each other
that are like parallel and they are
looking from three different views at
the same
place in the wires now in the
corridor
so
this is kind of where it gets a little
bit complicated but uh
i will try to explain as best as i can
so
uh
basically you can you can use the
information about the camera
position rotation and everything the
intrinsics and you can calculate like
relative position to another image
so like you you have groups of three
images you select two images from the
three the third one sorry i forgot to
explain the third one is just for
robustness so there is a case that the
virus overlap as i showed you before
then you can just skip the image and you
still have two so you need two images to
do this kind of stereo view and
reconstruct the 3d point and also you
need to know like that this power line
corresponds to this one so i just sorted
them left to right so the red one here
red one here and
that's it and then like you can se like
any point on this uh power line
and you will get a corresponding from
all of this information and a bit of
mathematics you will get a corresponding
point on the second one
and then you can just triangulate to
create the 3d point
but this is the happy case where like
you can simply sort them and there's
like five you know there is five wires
in the images so there's five on the
left five on the right but sometimes
like around the tower lines in the top
the towers it gets a bit complicated so
you need to kind of work around it so
you can actually take this point that
you just reconstructed and you can
project it to the next image and see oh
yeah this is the red power line because
you don't know yet like
so
then
okay then then you have like the 3d
points so you can triangulate it through
3d points you get this sort of
3d
view
and
there is some outliers so you want to
filter them out so you can fit the
physical model of the wire which is the
catenary curve model and you can fit it
robustly using something called random
sample consensus algorithm so you can
basically ignore those outliers because
like normal regression would not uh
capture this and it would like be
confused about it
so that's it now there are two point
clouds one one is of the terrain second
one is of the wires now we just combine
the combine them together calculate the
differences and this is done in a tool
that is called
cloud compare it is also open source and
uh it's like
one click of a button you can just
compute the distances and
you get this so it's this is a view of
the
power line corridor
so green is
uh like further than 50 meters red is uh
closer so here it is about 13.5 meters
from the wire
and you can get the gps coordinates of
that place so you can see there is
something wrong there you might need to
cut it like you may adjust for the
different
uh
uh like
requirements for height and width so you
can like have it a bit nicer so you can
see clearly the red parts are sort of
problematic everything else is fine
so we took three data sets one of them i
showed you already we tried uh some
some else
so this it always had five wires these
are 220 kilovolts power lines
uh so this is one this is
second
and that's it there is some results so
there is a comparison comparison of the
how many how much of the wires were
reconstructed from the neural network on
the left and from the
traditional methods on the right so you
can see in the third data set it was
really confused and there was like poor
lighting conditions as well but the
neural network still handled it
and for the accuracy you can actually
take from the terrain point
so some of those points were
reconstructed still even though it's
difficult for homogeneous structures so
i just took those points and compared
them with the reconstructed
geometrically constructed power lines
and this is the difference so like it's
a bit confused on the first data set but
on the
second and third it's like average
distance is seven centimeters or 18
centimeters which i think is really good
but we didn't have any sort of ground
through data because this really hard to
obtain
and you need a laser scanner for example
and it's expensive and stuff so it was
out of scope of this work
so that's
that's it for the
work
now
i wouldn't be talking to you if i
implemented this in java so
so obviously there are there is some
python there
if i just wanted to point out the
libraries that you can use to do some
something like this or similar so
anyone who already tried something with
computer vision you will know opencv
it's a very popular library so that's
can do anything with the images like the
traditional segmentation
then uh this
this library or framework included the
neural network so
you can just take it run it configure it
a little bit and uh pre-train it on your
data set uh it
works out of the box
uh then i used the sticky layer and
secured image for some of the
uh
like robust fitting the ranzak algorithm
uh shapely for geometry it's a very nice
one like it can only do 2d geometry but
it's very powerful it can do like
intersections and convex hulls and every
all of these things so that's a good one
and
something for package management so
and running the task
this one is
not in python but it has python
connector to it that's for the
reconstruction
from from the photogrammetry so building
3d models for images from images so if
you want to build the 3d models from
anything you can just take your phone
and like go around the rooms
room and take some pictures you can just
put it there and it will build you a 3d
model or any other software like this
there's like paid versions that are
quite good
and lastly there's the cloud compare for
the visualization comparing working with
point cloud
okay so that's it so what questions do
you have
okay so uh are there any direct
questions from the audience because
that's like okay so you take president
so for how long was the drone able to
fly because it was quite big
experience the big drones like you don't
do
so it's about 20 minutes okay so okay we
managed to fly like 500 meters with the
three flight strips so and by the then
you can swap out the batteries we had
like three gates you can just swap out
the batteries and while the drone is
doing another mission you can recharge
the old ones so if you have enough kits
of batteries you can just fly all day
can you can you do the wires just by
physics
what do you mean by physics
where they start
yes if you identify the precise point
where they start you should be able to
like
it's not important the altitude as much
as the like uh the distance from the
trees
but like they are due to different like
uh
weather conditions they can change in
altitude but
if that's not important to you then you
can just
do it based on physics
so yeah okay
or
um
high about the lines where you're going
to apply
why could you just come closer to see
the lines better
or is there like a sometimes
that you have to expect
is there some regulation yes
we flight about 70 meters above ground
and the wires were about 20 to 30 meters
above ground so there was enough room
you need permission to do it
so maybe a few questions from slido so
then yeah okay question there so um
first question did you consider using a
lidar instead of camera on the top of
that
well it is possible to do it using
lighter there are some studies that try
to do it using lighter but it's like
first it's very expensive to buy this
thing for a drone
and also hard to get
and then it's like very
hard to work with the data because
sometimes they are not precise enough
you have to do the flight again so we
just decided to go with the mainstream
and just use use images
which is much more versatile
another alternative solution for you
actually
flying along very long lines might be a
good task for a glider isn't it uh
it can fly for dozens of kilometers and
uh how could you compare it with uh
cocktails
glider you mean the drone with wings i
don't know i guess yeah because i think
the
trees like when they are searching for
robots they are using the guiding drones
yeah i think that's the goal eventually
it's quite hard to get it uh in into the
air and like manages because it's not as
versatile as the
quadcop
hexacopter
so eventually it should be possible but
you also need to fly higher it's just
more hassle to work with those but
it can fly like tens of kilometers at
one recharge so for this application
it's much more ideal
do you have a customer for this or is it
no if there is anyone in the audience
so
another question
uh maybe a very personal one what was
the biggest pain during
like the biggest thing would be if i had
to like actually work with the drone and
connect all this up and actually fly it
because that that's what my supervisor
helped me a lot with so i didn't
actually pilot the drone because i don't
want to lose 500
000 check rounds but and i also i don't
have the flying permits you need
actually to have a license for it so
that would be kind of difficult for me
oh the big okay now i know so the
the open drone map the software
it like it runs for 10 hours but at
some points it might just crash because
it ran out of memory so you like run it
overnight go to sleep and every every
morning you wake up and there is an
error because it crashed so that
happened to me like 20 times
so that was kind of painful but then we
figured it out gave it like 300
gigabytes of ram and it was happy
finally so
okay so there is the the last uh online
question and that's maybe a bit uh
related to this um how long does it take
to calculate all this uh meaning how
long does your cluster need to run to
get all information per meter or line so
the 3d reconstruction from the software
from the open drawn up that runs about
10 hours as i already said but it also
depends on the lightning condition so if
you have moving shadows in the image
when it's sunny it can take twice as
long for some reason
and this algorithm like the
reconstructing the power lines that
takes about one hour
where 500 meters of the lines okay
like 200 images was it
okay so and that was the last online uh
my question so are there any more like
live questions
okay
[Laughter]
luckily no but we actually lost the
drone once so
so it was flying there on its own and
sometimes it like loses the connection
between the controller and the drone and
it was like behind the trees so you we
couldn't see it on the display on the
controller but we couldn't even see it
with our own eyes so we were just hoping
it will eventually come back because
there is some failover like if it loses
connection but and it did but like it
was a stressful moment
why did you choose fight me for doing
this
what is that are you suggesting julia
i heard python is not very very fast
language so yeah there is a lot of a lot
of
you know computing
yeah the goal was not to be extremely
fast and also the library for the
photogrammetry which takes the 10 hours
is implemented in c and you can just use
it it's like a free project uh and my
algorithm took just one hour so compared
to that i decided
no point and there is an amazing
ecosystem of libraries and everything so
i wouldn't like be able to implement
this in c or java or anything because
opencv is not opencv is there but
shapely is not there
like half of the psychic is in fortran
right
yeah this library is okay highly
optimized okay any questions
second drone
well
it would be faster
so maybe
but they would have to like maintain the
overlap to be like close to each other
yeah it would be possible
okay well i have one bonus video for you
this is some somewhat related but i
actually found a drone that has a
flamethrower flamethrower
that burns this stuff down from the
power lines
now you know all of this can be
automated and it can fly on its own so
if you are not afraid of ai now you
should be
okay that's it
so if you want you can reach me out
there is the code if you want to see the
code on my gitlab you can reach me out
on gmail
or ask me any questions here
[Applause]